it is time to highlight a win for locals
as north las vegas park and sports
complex is being brought back to its
glory days if not better than ever
in north las vegas in the 1980s it was
the place to play ball it was the
genesis of sports here in the valley the
cheyenne sports complex that's our
intent is to bring it back to the hay
day and bring the 75 thousand folks back
here the central spot for recreation up
north has seen better days and it's
about to again the park is getting a lot
of needed attention it's about four
million dollar upgrade here to the park
resurfacing the track and tennis courts
lighting irrigation new turf paved
parking lots a playground and a giant
splash pad it's a lot of fun for the
kids splash pads are great from
everyone's perspective from a toddler
all the way up to my age the goal for
north las vegas of all ages to have a
fun safe place to play water and kids
it's a dynamic combination and it's
great for all
park goers and sisters elsa and annie
can't wait i think it's fun we like to
play and have fun waterside
slides
the bars
are you good at the monkey bars yes
is your sister as good as you
no esther a 14-year resident considers
the improvements a necessity for a safe
place to play the other children
they play in their houses because in
here if you don't have
where they can play no water no nothing
like that it's very important because um
where i live the children play outside
of my on my house and the cars cross the
street and everything and it's dangerous
and although esther is thinking about
the kids first a point of the park is to
also provide a place for seniors to
stroll because we need work every time
people like my age the project will be
complete in about 18 months we're
hustling with vast improvements filling
the expansive 38 acre park north las
vegas welcomed the change you're going
to know you're in a first class facility
for our citizens that's what we're after
for our folks to come over here and say
wow